I'll do whatever it takes to keep my
family safe
[Music]
you okay yeah I'm good just a little
nervous
well you look very handsome I just don't
want to screw it up you know you have
been preparing for this meeting for six
months you've got this mask you guys a
question
daddy loves to me dad loves it exactly
that is gonna go make that bacon gross
[Music]
mr. Sawyer is your family enjoying this
day very much so they're shocked you
gave us the entire floor after you
secured the assessment what do you think
of the building with all due respect is
glorified security guard please the
Pearl is the tallest most advanced
building in the world you've built a
vertical city but you've brought with it
every single safety and security
challenge that I could think of we
thought this flow was empty Saturday not
only have you brought them all indoors
but you've trapped them 240 floors in
the air no one really knows what would
happen if things go wrong but I'm just a
glorified security guard so what the
hell do I know anyway what's one on the
96 floors on fire you're gonna be just
fine I promise you
[Music]
tell me how much do you love your family
if we're gonna get out of here you're
gonna have to tell me the truth there's
a reason they chose this building
[Music]
my family's the only thing that matters
to me right now
[Music]
you
you